Olivier baaumont du Parisien Aujourd'hui
en France la question de Benjamin duamel
me laisse à penser que nous venons de
basculer dans la partie plus politique
de cette soirée j'aimerais revenir du
coup sur la nomination de votre nouveau
gouvernement nous avons eu quelques
surprises tout d'abord celle de Gabriel
Attal nommé comme premier ministre et
puis le retour d'une figure sarkoziste
Rach hadti qui avait appartenu au
gouvernement il y a une dizaine d'années
plusieurs questions me viennent en tête
tout d'abord pourquoi le choix de de C
cette personnalité à ce ministère là
deuxème chose qu'est-ce qui a changé
entre 2017 et aujourd'hui en 2017
François baerou qui avait été mis en
examen avait dû quitter le gouvernement
rachti est aujourd'hui misise en examen
elle vient d'être nommée au gouvernement
et enfin dernière question le sujet de
Paris on laisse à penser qu'il y aurait
eu un deal entre elle et vous concernant
les élections municipales en 2027 dans
la capitale merci de nous apporter
quelques éclaircissements merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup d'abord je vais i dire
les choses très clairement
François baayrou a pris la décision de
démissionner je ne lui ai pas demandé en
2017 il était garde des
saut j'ai eu ensuite plusieurs ministres
durant mon premier mandat qui ont été
mis en
examen et en effet ministre de la
Culture l' dans une affaire don je n'ai
pas à connaître au fond je me suis
appuyé sur un changement des règles
simples et aussi en regardant
l'évolution de notre vie politique et
Judici
depuis 10 ans maintenant dans notre pays
il n'y a plus d'instruction individuelle
sur les dossiers il y avait une vieille
jurisprudence qui existait dans notre
pays qui fait qu'en effet quand un
ministre était mis en examen il devait
quitter la table du Conseil parce qu'il
avait un de ses collègues qui pouvait
donner une instruction individuelle au
parquet c'est interdit maintenant il n'y
en a plus qui
plusé tous les membres du parquet que
j'ai eu à nommer depuis que je suis
président comme le faisait d'ailleurs
mon
prédécesseur l'ont été conformément aux
avis du CSM donc oui ce faisant il y a
pas de règle qui fait qu'un ministre
mise en examen devrait quitter parce que
sinon en quelque sorte je reconnaîtrai
moins un responsable politique la
présempption d'innocence qu'à d'autrre
il se trouve que d'ailleurs j'ai pu
avoir des ministres mis en examen qui
ensuite ont été innocenté je m'en
félicite pour eux ce qui montre plutôt
que c'est assez juste donc la justice va
faire son travail avec sérénité à son
rythme mais je considère il y a pas de
changement de règle il y a juste là
aussi une de bon sens pour le
reste j'ai proposé avec le Premier
ministre à madame Rachida Dati de
devenir ministre de la Culture parce que
son énergie son talent sa liberté parce
qu'elle ne se réduit pas à une
appartenance
politique je crois sont util à la
culture à ouvrir des portes et à
permettre au fond de mettre fin je le
disais c'est pour moi un de mes grands
objectif à cette France du c'est pas
fait pour
moi faut lutter contre
celle-ci nous n'avons pas parlé de Paris
vous aurez du mal à me croire quand je
vous dis ça mais c'est
vrai la seule chose que je veux pour
Paris c'est qu'un électeur puisse avoir
les mêmes droits et compter autant à
Paris qu'à à men à Besançon ou ailleurs
et donc que le gouvernement et le
Parlement puissent décider d'une réforme
en profondeur de la loi parislion
Marseille pour revenir au droit commun
ça je pense que c'est la bonne chose
c'est la seule chose qui me concerne
pour Paris le reste je sais qu'elle
mettra son talent son énergie et tout le
reste au service de la culture de ceux
qui la servent et de ceux qui veulent
aussi y avoir
droit